[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable nos soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant est ce que
peuvent faire un peu plus de 5000
militaires français à l'efficacité
certes reconnu sur une zone aussi vaste
même renforcé par cinq mille soldats
promis par les pays du sahel c'est là où
les problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin